what would be the next step to grow my
brand the right answer is at this second
and you may ping me in six months and be
like now and I'll be like you'll be
totally different but right this second
my actual answer is - you got your
prospective YouTube what's up so so
grateful that you clicked and you're
about to watch a new youtube video but
before you do - one two nine three one
five seven three one that is my texting
community platform doing a lot of
one-on-one engagement in there and also
access opportunity first looks in that
environment
- one two nine thirty one five seven
three one join it now and now to the
video you've been wanting to watch hello
ru hi Mimi hi hi Charlie hi hey how are
you yes a typical how can I help so I'm
on yep on where over the past not even a
month I've gained four million
and it came out me very very quickly
clearly from nothing to people knowing
who I am
yep and what that is a lot of pain
yep and I was just wondering like from
in school to comments like what's the
best way to deal with that my belief is
the best way to deal with that is
compassion if somebody at school or in
the comments is taking the time to watch
your videos and tell you that you're
ugly you suck you're stupid they're in a
very bad place I mean it I've been
taking heat for a decade and everyone's
like [ __ ] haters you know like like
delete it I've actually only seen it one
way from the first day in 2006 to now
which is thirteen years uh I feel bad
for them like I'm not even kidding and
I'm not talking like bad for them like
you're now cool and have four million
they don't have it I actually mean think
about how much it would suck to be in a
place in your life where you are so
hurting inside
that you want to drag somebody else down
compassion and empathy
I actually feel warmth towards the
people that hate me the most yeah it's
an unusual answer but I think it's why
I've been able to persevere for so long
with so much judgement thrown at me and
my whole career has been innovating in
the wine business in Silicon Valley and
now in the ad world like I I get hate
from people that are well-established
not from anonymous accounts because I'm
disrupting and that's not fun but um you
should be pumped that you are even in a
place where people can hate listen I
think I think if you're fortunate even
in the 43 seconds that I've been here if
you're lucky enough to have an
infrastructure around you that you've
already grew up with a good starting
point like you're already you know more
than halfway home
so my next question is as of right now
I'm just doing tick-tock okay
Instagram and what would be the next
step to grow my bread to quadruple down
on tick tock tick tock is in a place
similar to all the platforms before it
where write it this might be a little
bit boring of an analogy but I'll give
it to you anyway this is like real
estate and in the 1800's people bought
up the land that we're sitting on for
nothing the attention is so underpriced
on tick tock as you know there is no
version of you getting four million
followers on Instagram in a month
starting tomorrow
tick tock is so unique right now the
right answer is at this second and you
may ping me in six months and be like
now and I'll be like it'll be totally
different but right this second my
actual answer is to massively triple
down on tick tock like YouTube
everything's a thing as you know right
everything is a thing what I don't know
is I don't know you well enough to know
how you translate from tick-tock to
YouTube some people translate great some
people don't
yeah
yeah that's like because mostly I don't
do YouTube because you think you have to
do YouTube because you have something to
make got it yes not 51 yep I almost give
you a huge problem in your jacket so
good
thank you brother go ahead yes are you
guys scared we're kind of trying to
figure out like what's the endgame well
the number one thing to definitely do is
to not do the cliche thing that you know
all those like Hollywood parents did if
you you're not scared I love notice what
my first question was and as soon as you
answered the way you did I just got
happy now the only thing you have to do
is not do the horrible things that
parents do when these things happen
would just think they've got a Golden
Goose then I think you think she's not
the Golden Goose we don't need her you
guys are this is super awesome right a
lot of parents do need you know I'm in
the sports representation business now
these kids are at a lotto ticket and I'm
watching these parents and kids and I'm
[ __ ] devastated
that's enough at like you know this like
doing your thing like there's also your
own pride like I would like you don't
you don't want her to be the Golden
Goose even for your own [ __ ] manhood
right so so honestly now you just have
to care and like if she decides to like
it's all just being there like you've
been if she decides to quit after she
has 44 million followers and you like
what that's what she wants to do she's
the one that got him she's the one that
got the four million dollars I think
it's really a very very easy moment well
you know care make sure nothing crazy
happens but like the world is good like
this whole note like there's nothing
alike people don't get it I feel like
we're all just feeling
because there's all these great things
being thrown at us that we're trying to
navigate through him but none of the
perks
happened yet that come along with this
so meanings meaning all the hates there
but none of the money's there like like
just in its most or whatever yep but
what the hate but the hate is zero like
meaning the hate is doesn't know
anything - 51 year old guy it does if
you're willing to a hundred percent of
course it does to fit I like I am
empathetic to it it's why the first
question is the whole [ __ ] game all
the time should be spent on taking the
steam out of the hate if she was if I
was the fourth family member here and we
were hanging out every day it would just
I would be pumping into her head the
truth which is what I'm saying the hate
should be met with compassion I think
just honestly think about living a life
where you are interested in hating on
someone it's I really I'm not kidding I
think people sometimes want to hear me
say it because I say once in a while
like I don't think they believe me and
it's the thing I believe in the most I
don't feel you know it's it's hard if of
course you want to kill everybody of
course but but but it's hard when you're
taking affirmation from the outside you
know like in whatever form right if you
over value somebody complimenting you
that you're cool dad and you have Easy's
on then you're gonna over value the hate
- like I'm like literally my comments
are respect I love it and they look cool
but like literally my comments are
literally like you're a snake oil
salesman con artist and the next one's
your Jesus
like literally
like and I'm just like no no just and
the more she can practice it now and the
more you actually believe it and the
more that's the conversation and then
any advice like trying to everybody
wants to be in her world right now like
managers and there's some bad like any
advice on what what do you want to
happen do you know yet cuz it's fast you
may not and that's okay too
I'm not exactly sure I just know I
always want to go back to my kind of
home base of just being a dancer that's
been a good do that people overthink the
moment back to the Golden Goose
especially if you don't need it like if
she wants to monetize financially then
she should learn that from leaving her
alone and like learning that is even
more valuable than whatever happens of
it yes there's brand deals opportunity
there's there's things to be done my
belief is that the longer you can stay
pure the bigger you'll become especially
if you don't need it or necessarily are
yearning for it right now and there's no
reason to monetize oh she does managers
are gonna care about managers [ __ ]
they're gonna try to [ __ ] out so they
can make their 10 to 20 points the end
managers do managers [ __ ]
and parents you can't [ __ ] and I say to
her every day
are you happier today than you were to
two months ago one day this is gonna
become very very clear to you
you're a really lucky girl I mean it I
really mean it I do this a lot I know
what I'm talking about you're in a good
spot this is good more of that Dixie's
got six hundred thousand - yeah it
becomes a whole thing and like you know
like honestly this is what everyone's
gonna go through everyone's gonna have
followers not everyone's gonna have 400
or seven four million or 700,000 or
whatever it's gonna be able like and
look these are young girls - like
there's so many dynamics they've done
with their lives like you know like
there's so much to go like I get it and
that's that's intention now we're
starting to get into more interesting
conversation that's what you really want
you know that's now I'm looking at you
too like if I'm like the friend and
we're having glass so I'm like that's
intense cuz now I'm like now I'm like
are you are you willing to go with her
for these two years are you guys gonna
commute like can you up like I don't
know okay what dance okay got it
like is that in the car it's like will
you move oh great well then then it's
not complicated thing well I mean
business yeah let's go love it in this
is all intent if you don't intend on
monetizing your daughter if you intend
on focusing on her being happy right
your [ __ ] did a moonwalk to success
it's just intent
how do we get here yes everywhere but
how did it happen yep uh-huh
yep Dixie responded and then Jason good
old intern yeah that's awesome so that's
how the connection was made awesome
I hope this helped you're welcome so
much awesome cool thank you guys very
sweet thank you is are you in this world
yeah I'm in the main fact I handle sales
for business all these ghosts I love it
I own I actually looked at buying the
company a couple years ago when they
transacted I can't wait awesome so I'll
take a look I'm sorry I'm running a
little late
it's so nice to meet you guys let us
know if we can help by the way we're
thrilled it's like if you want to ask a
literal question it's like hey Reebok
reached out to us and offer us 25,000
bucks is that good is that bad like
anything we can answer we have a ton of
data you're welcome have a great day bye
guys
[Music]